I want to mention you have an upcoming
man you were busy you got the podcast
yeah you got this show bless this mess
ABC you've got an upcoming game show yes
yes called spin the wheel
you all should come on it you can win
twenty three million dollars what yeah
wait a minute did you say seriously did
you say twenty three million dollars
yeah that's no joke there's people who
have very successful show business
careers that don't get to half of that
right what are you talking about let's
like join it yes so the funny the best
part of it is it's a five story tall
roulette wheel
you know mounted vertically and I'm next
to it in the machine itself the
contraption it weighs 40 tons and I can
hear the whole time it's spinning I hear
bolts shearing off I hear like there's
like I can hear someone putting a brake
on but it's not slowing down many times
during the filming of it I thought I'm
this is how I'm gonna die most comedic
death of all time
Buster Keaton style but I don't make it
no no it would be so first of all people
would think as much as you're loved
people would laugh so hard if that thing
fell on you if you were killed by a
giant wheel of money yeah is the 23
million in the wheel well no it's got
all these you know digital displays the
different values of it but yeah I think
even my wife would get a hoot out of
that your funeral
completely flat coffin just mount the
coffin to one of the panes and just let
it spin
I've never enjoyed someone's death more